we got to go see Star Wars Battlefront
Walker assault mode I played as Imperial
you played his rebels since the did what
did you think as the rebels I think what
I mean one of the coolest things was
that trying to fight off the giant 8p
aps coming at you but it was kind of
tough to stop them I was entirely sure
how to do it with what we yeah the
Walker assault mode it felt a little bit
like kind of a rolling rush mode a
little bit of rush from battlefield but
basically the 80 80 s walk up the field
The Imperials play has just grunts like
protecting the legs of the acat keeping
the rebels from shooting it with I think
like ground ion cannons and then if it
gets hit enough times then you can the
rebels can attack it directly yeah so it
was it was a really interesting mode the
map opens up as you go so as the
Imperials capture points then you get to
play on the next section of the map and
the next section of the map which like I
said it's a lot like rush even at one
point went into a hot face did you play
first person or third person so I
switched between the 2 i'm mostly played
first person but i did try third person
a little bit i liked it i think it
worked I know the originals were mostly
we're all third person mostly and I was
kind of worried that it may not work too
well in it it felt good but I think
first person is probably the best way to
play this game yeah I was kind of
surprised I was a little bit skeptical
going in the e3 because the vast
majority of coverage of battlefront was
basically about what's not in the game
so this is the first time we actually
see what's in the game the Imperial
faction there was a couple of different
loadouts that I had one of them was a
bubble shield so because Hoth is such a
trench planet it's like world war one
style it was really important to like
pop your bubble shield or the other
claspers had a jetpack to get between
those open spaces quickly to get into
the trench and then basically capture
and hold these Walker assault points
yeah you wouldn't last too long if you
were out on the no man's land I guess I
had I had used the jet jump to get
around through there now one of the
things that it was interesting was the
way that you get into the 80s tease or
the x-wings were basically power-ups
like from mario kart really those weird
you run across the field and you'd hit a
powerup and some of the power-ups were a
TS TS
so you've got a chance to fly an x-wing
how did a flying feel it so I played a
little bit of first person in the x-wing
and then i put a little bit a third
person and it felt a lot like jets a
simplified version of jets from
battlefield it's not nearly as
complicated but it's I mean it is fun it
felt good did you manage to attack
ground targets in the 80 80 s a little
bit i flew in close i shot some people
on the ground off i killed anyone and
then i crashed but then I also i also
got a chance to fire the 8080 with that
and i think that is how i was able do
the most damage on i think so i got a
chance to to pick up an eight EST you
know you get the pick up you warp into
it and the 80s d was pretty powerful it
has killed me a couple times it's got
the main laser cannons it's got a
grenade launcher and it's got a rocket
so once you pick that thing up I don't
know I was able to hold down pretty much
a wave of rebels coming out of a hot
base for a while and then continue up
the map but it's still unclear at this
point like how often those pickups pop
up because the power ups from just
playing seem to be rocket launchers and
and some other things to help you on
your way yeah like there'd be grenades
like pickups like there'd be like a
little spinning sort of em blooming you
pick it up and you get a grenade which
is kind of weird and other times you'd
get a you'd get an x-wing or something
like that so my overall impression of
the star wars battlefront PvP session
that we saw was it was a lot better than
I expected frostbite is really good at
doing sound and I think that's a large
part of it the combat itself there was a
good variety of weapons there were close
range blasters there were like medium
range equivalent light machine guns and
then there was sort of like the
longer-range blaster class the blasters
themselves had a lot of like weight and
impacts and also the shots art because i
think in star wars universe it's not
lasers they're charged plasma so you
actually had to lead targets an overall
I was surprised how much it felt like a
world war one trench shooter for the
match them especially that last section
when when they were kind of making that
final push and there was basically just
trenches going
that was really cool so we'll continue
to look into Star Wars Battlefront and
bring you information for all your stars
battlefront coverage stay tuned to
gamespot com